Santiago muy buen día bueno lo que se
venía a venir las pruebas acercaron al
presidente Pedro Castillo en las últimas
horas uno de los más cercanos
colaboradores salatiel manuff reveló que
él entregaba dinero al mandatario
peruano 13 mil dólares más de 13 mil
dólares para que mantenga en el puesto a
un ministro del gabinete de vivienda
general varado quien después fue
destituido
general
barú reveló también que se le entregaba
dinero al presidente Castillo para que a
su vez este dinero sea entregado a
congresistas para que rechazaran las
votaciones en contra del mandatario para
que sea rechazada el proceso de vacancia
presidencial loelipipe estas y otras
declaraciones que se encuentran en
fiscalía promovieron a que el presidente
Castillo tomara esta decisión a última
de cerrar el parlamento peruano cerrar
también la fiscalía el poder judicial el
tribunal constitucional en las
siguientes horas Pedro Castillo va a
establecer un toque de queda en todo el
país que va a regir desde las diez de
esta noche Hasta las seis de la mañana
del día siguiente otras medidas que
también ha tomado es trabajar o mejor
dicho gobernar a
través de estos de emergencia y se va a
convocar a un nuevo proceso electoral ha
hecho el mandatario se va a convocar a
elecciones Próximamente y mientras tanto
él va a estar gobernando Obviamente que
con un parlamento disuelto el proceso de
vacancia presidencial que iba a ser hoy
a las quince horas Ya queda
definitivamente
inválido claro
qué es lo que vaya a pasar en estos
momentos es insostenible hay varias
marchas que se están convocando
Francisco contanos qué escenario se
abren a partir de ahora
Bueno ahora Pedro Castillo va a gobernar
a través de decretos de emergencia va a
tener que
Establecer un diálogo algunos
representantes del parlamento va a
funcionar la comisión permanente de este
hemiciclo que está siendo cerrado y a
través de cuatro meses me señalaba un
legislador hace unos minutos ahora la
cuestión va a ser en que Cuál es la
reacción que va a tener la fuerza
civiles sobre todo a las fuerzas de
oposición que están siendo dirigi el
parlamento por la derecha peruana Ellos
están señalando que Pedro Castillo está
evadiendo la justicia a la fiscalía y al
proceso que se le está pidiendo en el
parlamento porque no solamente en caso
fallar a este proceso de impeachment se
Estaba preparando un proceso de
destitución inclusive también de
suspensión del mandato
por 36 meses mientras fuese investigado
por la justicia ahora Pedro Castillo
está en estos momentos en el interior
del Palacio de Gobierno sosteniendo
reuniones con sus principales ministros
el mandatario se acaba de dirigir a los
peruanos hace unos minutos en un
sorpresivo mensaje a los peruanos